Why don't we go next to Trent from
Miami, Trent from Miami. You on the air.
Yes, hi, David, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Awesome. I have a question about the border wall
and the possibility of of Biden restarting it.
And there was that was a rumor that was flowing
around yesterday. And Representative Ellen Omar
said it would be really bad for Joe Biden to
continue building Trump's racist border wall.
And I had a discussion with my best friend
about whether Trump's border wall comes from a
racist place or not. And I was more leaning on
the side that that the wall, since it was being
pushed by certain right wing pundits and Trump and
Steve Bannon behind the scenes, that didn't work.
We're kind of leaning into this racially tinged
socioeconomic populist rhetoric that because
of that, the wall is inherently racist. My my
best friend wasn't seeing it that way. It was
he saw it more as well. We need border security
and. And we need to solve our illegal immigration
problem, so I don't really see where the racism
comes in. That's what my best friend said. So
I was just wanting to ask what? Because it's,
you know, these past four years have kind of all
blurred together, you know, with everything that
the former president has done. I got my.
Yes. So the question is whether whether I
think it's racist. Listen, please do what you
can to silence your discord. The buildings are
just unbearable. That's in the call and guide.
So please check that out. If you're unsure how to
do that. Here's the thing to say. Whether a wall
in a wall itself is just a wall. So I don't know
that we can say that a wall is racist. I think
the question is whether the intentions of those
looking to put up a wall are racist. And to be
perfectly frank, I think it doesn't matter. I
don't even engage with that issue because the
point is the wall doesn't really achieve what
we what we claim to want to achieve. It doesn't
really fix the issue of undocumented immigration.
Only a third of undocumented immigrants are
physically crossing the US Mexico border. Two
thirds are overstaying visas, just flying in for
a trip and never going home, etc.. The wall can be
defeated, as we've seen with like one hundred and
fifty dollars in parts from your average hardware
store. And the wall doesn't deal with the economic
situation in the countries from which people are
coming. And a far better investment would be to
deal with that by working with those countries.
So, you know, a wall is a wall. The reasons for
building it can be racist. Some of the people who
want the wall are racist, some maybe not. But
I don't know that it really matters too much
because there's other bigger issues with the wall
and with immigration policy that I would focus on.
Great, thank you, David.
All right, I'm going to let
you go. Thank you. Yeah. Instructions on how
to silence those discord Blinkx because those
people get very upset. I got
a lot of emails saying, David,
I can't listen to the calls when the
blinking and blinking and blinking.